on this martin luther king jr day i want  to remind you to be like  this guy i have a dream  my four little children  will one day live in a nation where they  will not be judged by the color of their  skin but by the content of their  character  i have a dream today  and don't be like this guy our priority  will be black latino asian and native  american-owned small businesses  women-owned businesses  if you're looking for more honest and  thoughtful conversations about politics  instead of non-stop yelling check out  our politics playlist  and if you want to watch full interviews  on a variety of topics watch our full  episode playlist  all right over here and to get notified  of all future videos be sure to  subscribe and click the notification  bell